il ya quelques semaines je vous emmener
à barcelone et je vous présentais le
nouveau aux normes magic quadrant ce
matin le nouveau au nord magic quatre
pros qui est le nouveau smartphone très
haut de gamme de chez eux au nord est
pour quoi ce truc là est vachement
intéressant tout simplement parce que
c'est la première fois qu'on voit
arriver au nord en france avec un
smartphone très haut de gamme s'il vous
marque magic 4c qui a déjà eu des magic
mais il y en a pas eu ici on a eu en
asie donc là c'est vraiment déjà d'une
un gros come back on a eu l'année
dernière déjà qu'ils arrivaient on a vu
avec leonor 5 ans parce que au nord
s'est détachée de huawei et a récupéré
deux faits les services google qu'on
retrouve ici et ça c'est très bien et le
deuxième point c'est effectivement
l'élargissement de la gamme avec une
gamme complète que ce soit du côté des
ordinateurs des montres et compagnie
mais surtout au niveau des smartphones
avant c'était la marque jeune de huawei
avec des produits pour un public plus
jeune maintenant c'est une marque avec
des produits transverse de tous les
côtés avec du très haut de gamme de
l'innovation est le client on en
reparlera une prochaine fois mais
surtout ici avec honor magic quatre pros
qui fait de supers progresse en photo ou
en vidéo donc aujourd'hui c'est une
vidéo qui est réalisé en partenariat
avec honor aux normes a dit tiens
monsieur gros est ce que tu voudrais pas
un boxer regarder puis voir un peu le
disent tous que tu penses toi de ce
smartphone donc aujourd'hui on va
regarder on va l'ouvrir aux raiders
espoir parce que voir des gens nés tout
un sachet j'ai peint tout en vous
laissant peu la hotte du père noël est
pas exactement presque et puis après on
va laissant le terrain on va commencer à
chuter faire des premières photos vidéos
puis de le tester et je vous en parlais
avec le jour on y va
[Musique]
regardez la première chose à faire c'est
de vous nourrir hop on arrive
directement sur le smartphone notre
force ça c'est un exemple envoyer huit
mois pour la pression ça je peux enlever
notre force c'est ce qui est intéressant
si vous voulez que ce smartphone c'est
que comme je vous ai déjà présenté toute
la fiche technique je vous invite à
aller voir la vidéo dans lequel je vous
dis tout le lien je vous le mets quelque
part par là où quelque part par en haut
vous saurez tout va pas se faire le tour
de la fiche technique parce qu'on l'a
déjà vu elle est très complète on va
regarder les différents points à
regarder l'expérience au niveau de la
boîte alors c'est vrai qu'il fait quand
même un petit pois ssp noté 4 215 g je
crois on le sent mais je continue à bien
et b cette couleur j'avais vu sous des
éclairages saoulé dans le salon mwc ce
n'était pas extraordinaire
là sous l'éclairage de mon studio sarsan
vachement bien le scion et jolie il est
incurvé c'est une très jolie bête à
l'intérieur de la boîte qu'est ce qu'on
attend d'eux quoi ouvrir le tiroir de
cartes sim d'aller regarder fait
vachement intéressant de voir apparaître
en bas car ce soit il est là et de voir
ici s'est doublée d'un possible s'il 2,6
mhz un jeune créateur classe parce que
c'est tous plus il est d'accord côté
l'écran j'ai compris aux personnes comme
ça donc ici pas d'extension de cartes
mémoires mais de notre côté comme c'est
un smartphone qui arrive avec une grosse
config au niveau de la mémoire vous avez
soit 256 72 autant vous dire que je pas
sûr qu'on ait besoin de rajouter de la
mémoire ici ensuite à l'intérieur de la
boîte on retrouve un bloc de charges ça
se fera aujourd'hui donc ça c'est un
bloc de charge qui est très très fat et
c'est pareil je vous l'avais déjà dit
lors de la présentation
c'est du 100 watts ça ça vous leurs
charges extrêmement vite et ça c'est
cool ensuite dans la boîte on va avoir
un petit câble et puis c'est tout aille
là j'ai une petite cour intérieure ok
donc c'est très très très minimaliste ce
qu'on va me retrouver là mais on à
l'essentiel et ça fonctionne alors je
tiens à vous montrer qui est vachement
intéressant calais ça se trouve dans
cette boîte l'accès plus qu'une boîte
c'est un gros sac au nord alors ça ça va
vous intéresser je pense parce qu'il
existe également aux doors magic 4 light
qui sera moins cher que le promet qui en
fera tout autant avec le même design
c'est à dire un plat voyez on retrouve
la même idée en fait ici avec ce côté
asymétrique alors c'est un peu plus
petits au fera moins de choses on n'a
pas d'une périscopique iront le voir
parce que là on a loupé périscopique cas
qui promet d'avoir un zoom numérique
jusqu'à x 106 ça sera pas le cas donc on
en fera un petit peu moins il est un peu
moins épais mais bon on retrouve le même
esprit donc voilà pour le la boîte du
live que je voulais vous montrer qu'il
ya autre chose qui est très intéressant
et que au nord nous a sorti ses salles à
ça c'est le blog de charge sans fil en
fait que vous allez avoir c'est de la
charge son fils 100 watts donc ça vous
permet d'avoir la même expérience en
termes de rapidité au niveau
filaire que vous allez retrouver
directement avec le chargeur inclus dans
votre boîte mais également sans fil donc
ça c'est quand même super bien regardez
moi ce truc c'est énorme donc là je
prends obligeant retire ça je pose mon
smartphone et là il va surcharger en 100
ans wade filaire ce qui fait que lorsque
vous arrivez au bureau chez vous le
prenez vous le posez vous êtes
tranquilles en une demi-heure avant de
charger de 0 à 100 % et de 0 à 60 %
seulement 15 minutes donc ça quand même
super cool alors vous mettez sur votre
gros il ya un petit ventilateur derrière
laquelle juste la saison cela je prends
la bête et je la pose c'est pas le
boulot tout de suite rien du tout
l'entraîneur chargé foyer est l'icône
qui est là la décharge ok ça marche on
va donc faire un truc tout de suite on
va prendre ce smartphone on va parti on
va aller dans la rue on va commencer à
faire quelques photos quelques vidéos on
va regarder quoi ça ressemble on va
regarder si les résultats s'il
intéressant aussi les pros vent et puis
on va venir débriefer ici quelques
instants après et puis dans quelques
temps on se retrouvera pour une vidéo de
test complet où je vous donnerai mon
ressentiment autour parce que retourner
voir la vidéo de présentation parce que
ce sport soit il fait de très jolies
promesses au niveau de la photo vous
avez un triple capteur de 50 nettement
double capteur 50 méga pixels grand
temps ultra grand-angle et vous avez un
60 mégapixels sur le zoom le périscope
où on a un zoom optique x 3,5 et un zoom
numérique jusqu'à fois s'en est en fait
ils font un truc au nord qui est
intéressant c'est ce qu'ils appelleront
de l'ultra fusion en fait que l'ultra
fusion c'est intéressant parce que
lorsque vous allez venir faire une photo
avec votre ultra grand angle vous êtes
sur un x 0,8 on va se dire sans votre
grand angle vous êtes sur un x 1 et si
vous partez sur le périscope vous partez
à partir des 6 d'un froid 3.5 qui vous
monte jusqu'à + l'infini c'est à dire
que lorsqu'il va venir vous faire une
photo avec l'ultra grand temps les bains
il va venir choper un dub ou d'image il
va prendre le x 8 et va venir prendre un
peu sur le grand angle pour venir
améliorer la photo est pareil à se
réunir faire les photos ac le grand
angle le grand-angle il va venir choper
aussi un peu au niveau luttera grand
angle et au niveau du zoom périscopique
en fait ce que ça fait c'est que vous
n'avez pas un seul capteur qui va
enregistrer vous allez avoir deux
capteurs qui vont enregistrer en même
temps et qui vont venir combinées des
parties qui se chevauchent sur les
photos par exemple je viens voir une
photo là une photo là une trois photos
là donc là c'est monde ultra grand angle
assez mon grand angle donc là je vais
avoir mon bonhomme au centre voyage de
signes vachement bien sûr les ultra
grand-angle de mon bonhomme il va être
un peu plus petit parce que ultra
grand-angle et surmont zoom de mon
bonhomme il va être carrément plus gros
comme ça avec les bras là et bien lui ce
qu'il va dire faire il va venir choper
voyez parce qu'en fait ce monde ultra
grand temps que si je recadre par
rapport à mon grand angle ça me ferait
un cadre à peu près comme ça pour lui
pour sortir une image comme ça il va
venir choper sont ultra grand-angle par
exemple il va venir me choper le cadre
de mon grand angle il va venir en
récupérer d'avenir superposés tout ça et
grâce à de la photographie
computationnelle c'est à dire de
l'intelligence artificielle va venir
optimisé l'image et de la même manière
par exemple ici la voyez il va prendre
le cadre ici par exemple de monter les
objectifs donc j'aurais eu la meilleure
qualité ici d'image et il va venir me la
superposer avec mon grand temps qu'on
peut faire en gros une meilleure photo
en gros ce qui va faire il me fait un
espèce de bouillie bouliac j'ai pas
comment dit à sa sauce où il ya
superposé différentes parties d'image
pour vous sortir la meilleure photo et
tout ça avec deux lits a donc ça c'est
plutôt pas mal et aujourd'hui on aurait
le seul à faire ça c'est à dire de
l'ultra fusion alors je vous explique ça
comme ça mais ça peut être aussi des
petits bouts d'image sur les côtés enfin
bref le tout qui est assez intéressant
[Musique]
là on est sur le mode vidéo regardez ce
qui est hélas en vidéo c'est que je
viens là j'ai dans le format de l'image
donc là je peux choisir je me suis mis
en 4/3 ça me va bien et ensuite j'ai la
résolution de la vidéo j'ai différents
formats compter jusqu en 4k 21,9 4k 16,9
c'est ce que j'aime c'est ce qui me va
bien et après descendre pour moi ça
servira à rien donc de venir enregistrer
comme ça après fréquence d'image je suis
en 30 images ça me suffit largement pour
ce que je fais pas besoin de mettre en
en 60 que vous montrez d'autres ici
l'agly et compris donc ça pour l'instant
on s'en fiche un petit peu donc ça c'est
une mode un peu classique hop je peux
passer ensuite en large je peux passer
en x 5 qui est le point ce fait là bas
et je monte jusqu en finisse c'est ça
c'est le mac ce que je peux faire ça y
va un peu fort au niveau du zoom n'y a
pas de truc qui va un peu doucement mais
bon on peut le faire comme ça ok je me
remets en attaque en fois intense et le
mode vidéo j'ai également la caméra de
celle ci à l'écouté voyez je suis la
coupe donc lâché en plan large je me
mets en x 0,8 ça ne sert un petit peu
parce que j'ai un grand-angle en fait
200 degrés la cendre la caméra de cette
fille je peux mettre un point donc là je
suis enfin je suis vraiment normale suit
au plus près et voyez je peux venir
m'éloigner faut 8 et plans larges alors
après il ya un autre truc à voir ici
fait lorsque je la prends la main comme
ça est-ce que je suis un peu stabilisé
j'ai l'impression et lorsque je switche
derrière c'est pas mal un registre pas
maintenant je vais enregistrer
directement la cecc l'enregistrement la
capture de l'écran je vais passer
directement sur la vidéo alors après il
ya notre mode fier d'être super
intéressant c'est le mode film alors hop
ça c'est le mode film et maxime c'est
vraiment le mot lorsqu'on venir s'amuser
alors là ça devient une espèce d'effet
éblouissante parce que c'est je vire je
vais dans mes lot et la radeej
différents effets colorimétrique donc
lâché en classique je peux mettre en
éclat de soleil ou là c'est chaud ça
c'est très très chaud focus c'est
bizarre ça me garde certaines couleurs
et pas d'autre qui ait fait voir du
hockey ensuite je m'appuie sur lot g
coire bravoure éblouissant où elle c'est
différent petit filtre de colorimétrie
alors c'est pas forcément ce que je vais
venir commander moi ce que je vous
recommande c'est de sortir de là et
d'utiliser le log alors ça c'est un mode
flat en fait l'image allait paraître et
transparente et en fait ça vous permet
de garder toutes les couleurs tous en
fête sans rien soit cramer et la faisait
parvenir éditer directement dans votre
logiciel donc ça on s'le regardera dans
quelques jours parce que je vais faire
un petit film avec qui se forme lorsque
ça raconte donc là je filme en flat et
en flat je peux venir passer jusqu en
faut 2 puisque pas monter plus c'est x 1
x 2 et si je rêve
lettres normal c'est pareil mode film
c'est assez x 1 x 2 tu peux pas aller au
delà vaut mieux se rapprocher de ce que
ça sent après on va dégrader la qualité
donc ça c'est pour le match in bon après
j'ai un mode pro qui est un peu
classiques comme sur tous les
smartphones je vais avoir un mode storia
s'en fiche un peu du match coriace et
des petits effets j'ai un mode super
macro l'on approche ouais c'est pas
stabilisée comme d'hab bon je peux dire
faire les photos en super macro hockey
ensuite j'ai le mode portrait que la
caméra de teuf derrière normalement ça
devrait pas mal de faire le cliché
nocturne en gardera sa mode ouverture
aussi bon ok priorité à l'ouverture ça
fonctionne et après j'ai un autre mode
je vais donc plus c'est le mode multi
vidéo c'est eux qu'on trouve un peu
partout aujourd'hui ça vient vous
partagez en faites la voyager caméra de
celle-ci caméra arrière donc là je peux
venir changer même sur la caméra arrière
je peux venir nous met directement dans
l'écran ok j'ai arrière-arrière sur le
grand angle et luttera grand-angle danse
est grand temps les téléobjectifs j'ai
l'impression g l'incrustation où
l'action tout petit ce que je peux me
déplacer à si je peux me déplacer
ensuite j'ai quoi d'autre j'ai que
l'arrière est mon intérêt que l'avant et
puis voilà arrières avant c'est assez
marrant pourquoi pas donc l'agent gist
directement voiliers se tenir la main
comme ça je sais pas si ça vous jouissez
si ça tremble champions qui s'étaient
massés stabilise et hop voyez comme ça
les enfants 08 si je me mets en fois un
cerf d'assez bien fonctionné donc là
l'autre côté je suis en fois un bien
léger décalage à l'écran en khadir qui
est une stabilisation numérique ensuite
je peux venir switcher je peux venir
reculer en x 0 large 5 donc oui ça c'est
extrêmement large les pareil j'ai
l'impression c'est comme stabilité d'un
point de vue numérique donc c'est quand
même plutôt pas mal et après je peux
monter je peux monter jusqu'en classe
est assez smooth sa pelouse comme ça là
je monte jusqu en 3
x 10 x 10 vidéos de ce que je vois avec
l'as table numérique certes est plutôt
pas mal comme ça bougeait un peu quand
même entre eux disent j'ai reculé un peu
je veux tu du recul dans les voitures là
bas voyez hop là je peux comprendre m en
x 1 voies la fois donc là je suis en
foin comme ça ça a fonctionné je vais
faire quelques photos très rapidement
histoire de voir un petit peu ce que ça
raconte tout de suite alors il se peut
qu'ils aient une mise à jour qui
arrivent pour venir corriger certaines
choses je ne sais pas je vous le dis il
faudra voir ça c'est un premier jet
c'est pas du tout un test sans vraiment
en premier jet au niveau photo niveau
vidéo vous l'avez vu donc on regarde ça
premiers clichés ici pris sur le grand
pont
alors la macro c'est toujours très dur
en fait il voulait de bien trouver le
bon point la bonne distance tout en
sachant qu'ici je n'ai pas de
stabilisation optique sur mon grand
angle et monde ultra grand-angle donc
c'est me concerne en tout cas vu que
j'ai un tremblement essentiel devenir
choper le le bon truc mais bon voilà
c'est pas surprenant on continue ça
c'est la caméra un grand-angle ou qui
ont souhaité sur l' ultra grand-angle en
garde petite différence de colorimétrie
mais ça c'est une différence de capteur
n'est pas surprenant on vient se
rapprocher on est en x 3 et mila j'ai dû
monter en x 10 et là j'ai fait un x 100
mais bon dans les arbres façon
globalement voyait les planches de bons
du tout caméra de celle fille c'est un
poil crabos derrière au niveau des
branchages on en voit où ça fait ça
c'était le x 0,8 ça c'est le large très
grand-angle lorsqu'on se rend que la
caméra telle fille et puis ensuite le
fois un hook et ça marche vanessa
beaucoup mieux la clé ciel un courrier
comme ça par contre il ya un peu de
bruit avoir faudra continuer à tester
avaler ce n'est pas une petite mise à
jour logicielle des fois ça vient
corriger certains trucs ou qu'ils aient
ça c'est ma caméra principale ou grand
angle ultra grand-angle le x 3 ennemis
kaki bientôt trois ans et demi bon même
à la balkanisation ça bouge un peu
encore en fait trop et demi et là je me
suis rapproché et là je suis au foie
sent bon les 60 façon globalement pas
faire grand chose pareil ici l'autre
lumière il est un petit peu de mal je la
pense que c'est assez imprécis en fait
c'est parce que c'est moi qui bouge et
que j'ai aucune stabilisation optique
tout qu'un point le relou faudra tester
un faudra voir donc on regardera ça lors
des tests mais moi ce que j'aime bien
c'est le x 3 mx trouve très très bon le
périscope là il est il est bien large
bien encore un peu de maquereaux ça
serait pas mal hein globalement voyez
qu'on appelle à bonne distance bon c'est
assez rigolo c'est pas des photos pour
venir agrandir et développer et mettre
dans son salon mais on sent les choses
un petit peu hollywood bon ok voilà
c'est vraiment un premier jet je voulais
qu'on commence à regarder sans ensemble
parce que pour moi ce smartphone si vous
voulez il ya un côté un peu événement
pourquoi mais tout simplement parce que
c'est le premier smartphone très haut de
gamme qu'on voit arriver chez au nord
avec ce magic quatre pros le client n'a
vu le magic v mais on verra l'histoire
dépliant mais c'est pas pour tout de
suite elle sera pour probablement plus
tard donc on verra on continuera à
suivre l'histoire ce smartphone là on va
se prendre un peu de temps va le tester
à faire des vidéos beaucoup de vidéos
avec quoi sert un petit film avec parce
que ça fait vraiment partie de son adn
et on voit qu'on est de plus en plus
nombreux à faire du contenu vidéo à
partager sur les réseaux que sur youtube
ou bien évidemment stoke instagram et
compagnie donc la vidéo est
prépondérante elle est partout on sera
également un test un peu plus tard un
peu plus complet sur le smartphone au
niveau de l'écran parce qu'il est aussi
un très très bel écran ltp au
rafraîchissement variable de jusqu'à 120
m bref vous passez un peu l'histoire il
ya beaucoup de performance derrière donc
on va recadrer ce smartphone s'il tient
ses promesses et sans leurs gardes dans
quelques temps dont je vous invite à
venir vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà
le cas cliquez sur le petit bouton rouge
et vous accédez la cloche sonnera vous
serez notifié dès qu une prochaine vidéo
arrivera et puis bien évidemment si vous
avez des questions des suggestions et
n'importe quoi sur ce smartphone voulait
marquer dès maintenant en bas en
commentaire parce que je regarderai et
j'essaierai de répondre très tôt qu'à
tous les pains vous l'avez donné lors du
test on se retrouve très bientôt pour
continuer à parler du aux normes hadji
quatre pros et du plein de choses donc
ça c'est cool vous embrasse pour les
soigner vous il ya très bientôt ciao
[Musique]